[موسيقى]
انا ليت الشباب يعود يوما فاخبره بما فعل
المشيب تلك المقوله الشهيره لا تنطبق على
هذه المسنه المكسيكيه فالقدرات التي تتمتع
بها جعلتها تبدو وكانها شابه يافعه في عمر
العشرين
وايجابياتها وحماسها عذابها عشرات السنوات
الى الوراء انها العجوز العنكبوت في
المكسيك تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده
من عالم غريب
[موسيقى]
هنا في ولايه اوكتان جنوب المكسيك تعيش
الجده دونامي شيتا التي تنحدر من سلاله
المايا هذه المسنه قرب عمرها 89 عاما
وتعرف في قريتها باسم الجده العنكبوت
والسبب انها تتسلق اشجارا في باحه منزلها
على طريقه سبايدر مان الشهير من الفيلم
السينمائي لتجني الفاكهه بيديها وتبيعها
وتكسب قوت عيشها من شده تتسلق بطريقه
مبتكره حيث تتكئ على حائط قريب من الشجره
وتصعد بجسدها للاعلى مستعنه بقدميها
ويديها لا غير
عارف
[موسيقى]
عمر هذه الجده الشجاعه لم يمنعها من العمل
اعمالا شاقه ربما لا يقدر عليها بعض
الشباب فهي تواصل تقطيع الحطب والاعتناء
بمحاصيرها والخروج لبيعها بنفسها وتجني
بذلك نحو دولارين في اليوم الواحد
هكذا
[موسيقى]
في كثير من الاحيان ياتي الزبائن الى
منزلها ويطلبون الفاكهه دون تعتمد على
نفسها في التسلق لقد طلبت بناتها واحفادها
مع مرور الوقت التوقف عن القيام بذلك ولكن
هذه هي طريقه عيشها منذ وفاه زوجها قبل
عشر سنوات قائله ان هذا يجعلها سعيده
من شتاء قالت انها سعيده بحياتها مؤكده
انها تصنع ايضا منتجات اخرى للبيع
كاليقطيني مع السكر فيما اكدت ابنتها انها
تعاني من امراض الشيخوخه لكنها تتمتع
بطاقه غريبه والسر في طب ما هي التقليدي
[موسيقى]